national parks are incredibly safe
places but when you have millions of
visitors coming through every year crime
will happen
hi my mom what's your address emergency
my name
is work
[Music]
my wife has fallen in really critical
condition i didn't rescue him
immediately
i was told to go to deer ridge trailhead
at that time i thought it was just a
tragic accident
a lot of things here don't add up
from the outside looking in tony and
harold's marriage looks like the perfect
life every year on their anniversary
harold would plan a trip
the phones ran and it's my brother my
brother said tony's been in an accident
she was gone
now we have an investigation we have to
conduct
there were small things that didn't
totally add up there's an obscure area
it was just so steep
he said he was doing cpr the whole time
her lipstick
was not smudged there was something more
to the story most people didn't know
that harold was married before
this is two wives for harold that have
died now and that was very suspicious
there's still a lot of questions we need
to ask harold told a lot of different
stories he's not telling the truth that
can't be possible
harold had purchased life insurance
months prior he's going to make a small
fortune i was shocked
he had been planning this for a while
something's not right here
[Music]
you